الى الولايات المتحده حيث لا يمكن اعتبار
ترشح ترامب لسباق الرئاسه مفاجئا فالرجل
اصلا هو ملك المفاجات واسمه لم يغب عن
الساحه حتى حين هزم وتولد جو بايدنس ضد
الحكم في يناير من العام الماضي ومن داخل
مقر اقامته في منتجع مره لاغو بولايه
فلوريدا اشعل ترامب فتيله سباق 2024 وقف
الرجل ضد 76 عاما معلنا ان بقى ترشحه في
خطاب استمر اكثر من ساعه هذه المره كانت
استراتيجيته مسبطا على انتقاده ادارات
غريبه وايضا وتعديد اسباب فشلها من وجهه
نظائح
[موسيقى]
ياباني تصنع
[تصفيق]
اقتصاد امريكا وجعلها في اخر الركب
الله يسعدك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كويس
ركز ترامب بشكل خاص على ثغرات بيدن التي
يرى ترامب انها حولت امريكا الى بلد غارق
في العنف والجريمه تخنقه الاسعار المرتفعه
ويعبر ملايين المهاجرين غير الشرعيه حدوده
مع المكسيك وفيما يتعلق بالسياسه الخارجيه
بانه يقود العالم الى حافه حرب النوويه
بسبب موقفه من الازمه الاوكرانيه مجددا
دعوته لمؤيده لنجعل امريكا عظيمه مره اخرى
تويتر
[تصفيق]
اعتبر ان ترامب خذل امريكا وانه خلال
رئاسته تربع على اقتصاد مزور لصالح
الاثرياء وهاجم النظام الصحي ودلل
المتطرفين وهجمه حقوق المراه وحرض
العصابات العنيفه في كل الاحوال
ستكون مختلفه عن سابقتيها كثيرا فاغلب
دائرته الضيقه لم تعد موجوده ابنته
ايفانكا اعرضت عن دعمها لها طبعا لكنها
اكدت انها ستختار هذه المره اعطاء
الاولويه لاطفالها ولحياتها الخاصه هذا
فضلا عن انقسام الجمهوريين حول شخصه خاصه
بعد النتائج الضعيفه التي سجلها في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي فضلا عن ان اكثر
من جمهوري تراوده احلام الترشح اكثر
الوجه الاكثر جاذبيه الان في الحزب حتى
القنوات الاخباريه اتخذت موقفا غير معتاد
من ترامب مثلا
خطابه كاملا واشارتا الى انهما ستعودان
اليه اذا استدعى الامر ذلك
سيكون على ترامب اذا ان يستدعي نجاحاته
السابقه في المكتب البيضاوي اهمها شعبيه
لدى المحافظين خاصه بعد تعييناته لقضاه
المحكمه العليا
وتخفيضات الضريبيه الكاسحه التي سنها فضلا
عن رعايته لاتفاقات سلام في الشرق الاوسط
وقت الزعيم تنظيم داعش ابو بكر البغدادي
لكن لا شيء مضمون بالنسبه لترامب قبل ان
يفصل القضاء في الاتهامات المواجهه اليها
طبعا احداث الكابتل وتحريض المتظاهرين في
المقدمه والتعامل غير المدروس مع الكورونا
وتراجع دور الولايات المتحده عالميا ايضا
لا ننسى ملف الوثائق السريه والملاحقات
الضريبيه لعائلته كل هذه الملفات قد تؤدي
في النهايه لاستبعاده هذا ان لم ينجو كما
نجع من محاولات عزله وهو رئيس
[موسيقى]